were you Star Struck uh yes but not a
star truck as I was when I ended up with
Vincent Price oh I ended up you ended up
with Vincent Price I ended up having
dinner with Vincent Price and his wife
was her name Carl Brown and at Roddy
McDowell's house come on and Roddy did
it because I had originally written
Fright Night for Vincent Price I thought
he would play
you know it was Peter yeah right right
right and well that's why I'm Peter
Vincent the uh his surprise and Peter
Cushing and uh I I sat there and wanted
to talk about all the great horror
movies that that Vincent Price had had
made and all he wanted to talk about was
Art and the cookbook he just finished
so I couldn't get anything out of them
really but just listening to that voice
yes yes yes yes ghouls from every two
two
even though you try to you know who that
is right yeah you know that's impressive
Thriller yes he was also in The Brady
Bunch but he did a lot of movies he was
in The Brady Bunch he was in an episode
of The Brady Bunch years ago that I
didn't know yeah I think they went to
Hawaii and uh Vincent Price was was
there and he was kind of this eccentric
character but yeah he was but he also
did Wax Museum and no he could really
act oh man he was great he had such a
presence yes but he could do character
work too if you go back and look at the
movies in the 40s and the 50s you could
see him really working Noir he did noir
films right